I'm going to talk about innovation we
want to talk about new industries we're
going to talk about New York want to
talk about does New York play a role in
the world not in the United States it's
not hard to compete with other cities in
the United States New York must compete
with other centers in the world and can
New York be a great center for
innovation and growth of new industries
once again it's done it many many times
gone through many many cycles so I'd
like to introduce this panel are our
Pettitte's and our Rivera's and are so
first is Jay apt j would you join me on
the stage a apt is the executive
director yeah that's fine good jay is
the executive director of the Carnegie
Mellon electricity industry center he is
also an associate research professor at
the temper school of business as well as
a distinguished service professor in the
Department of Engineering and public
policy in the College of Engineering is
there a school you don't work for not
one that John he doesn't do it doesn't
do anything HHS s no II don't know okay
so Alfred Spector Alfred can you join us
Alfred is the vice president of research
and special initiatives at Google in
this capacity he's responsible for the
collection of special projects of
strategic value to the company but that
are somewhat outside the mainstream of
its current products I don't know if
there is an anything outside of Google's
mainstream any longer no one's safe from
google previously he served as a tenured
faculty member in Carnegie Mellon's
computer science department third is
David Steiner David
david is the chairman of Steiner
equities group he's had a long and
distinguished history as a real estate
developer with his son Douglas david has
also built Steiner Studios a film and
television production company that
opened in 2004 in Brooklyn David is the
graduate is a graduate of Carnegie
Institute of Technology and finally but
not least David Tepper Dave David is
president and founder of appaloosa
management David earned his mba from
Carnegie Mellon I hate to admit he's a
pit graduate that's another joke I'll
tell you sometime appaloosa management
is a seven billion-dollar hedge fund
1212 oh and that just happened today it
was seven yesterday twelve
billion-dollar hedge fund investment
based in Chatham New Jersey in a march
two thousand four Carnegie Mellon's
graduate school of industrial
ministration was formerly known for a
long time as GSA was formally named the
David a temper school of business after
the generous gift made by david and his
wife Marlene the gentleman welcome I'm
going to move over here and my mic
should still work yeah that's great yeah
so let me let me get down to it by the
way these questions have been sealed in
a hermetically sealed jar actually
they've seen the questions and the
answers first question historian John
Steele Gordon wrote an essay for the
wall street journal in September called
don't bet against New York in it he
wrote only time will tell if New York
will do what has done so many times
before recover from economic disaster
and become bigger better richer and more
diverse than it was before but I
wouldn't bet against it deep within the
heart of this vast metropolis like the
child within the adult there is still to
be found
that little husky bussli live and let
live let's make a deal Dutch village and
the creation of wealth is still the
city's dearest love so guys from your
perspective on New York the way you look
at it whether it's arts finance IT
energy or whatevers perspective you look
at New York how do you feel about this
statement how do you feel about New
York's future and what role do you think
New York will play in the next 30 years
anybody can start all right well shoot i
mean my perspective is New York is about
money right anybody not think that so
let me tell you a little energy story
right I study the electric power
industry it's a 450 billion dollar a
year industry that'd get your attention
even if you live in New York but I got
to tell you something because of what's
likely to happen sometime with carbon
dioxide control in the US there's going
to be another hundred billion dollars a
year added to that industry that's not
interesting to anybody in this room okay
even in New York a hundred billion
dollars a year sounds pretty good that's
about twice the size of Microsoft every
year I think there's going to be people
in this room are going to get very very
involved in something that big David you
know you created five billion dollars in
last 24 hours so actually it's actually
the last two weeks but last two weeks
okay well two weeks I said so much um
look I mean you just you know I can tell
you today why New York's never going to
stop I'm just outside and you know I was
approached a couple times by people in
this room and you know who you are you
know about a you know businesses that
are starting up it never stops and it
will never stop whether it's somebody
just you know coming from Pittsburgh or
somebody's I guess which Pittsburgh
Stanford Pittsburgh if I got that right
you know who you
are you know one way or another you end
up in New York and this is the center of
commerce the center of Finance what has
always been and always well I want to
tell you from a different perspective my
industry is small potatoes compared to
these guys here but I I'm a civil
engineering graduate who somehow in a
momentary aberration went into the film
business I built movie studios at the
behest of by some violating my three
basic principles stick to what you know
don't roll a ranch and figure the odds
carefully but there I am but I want to
tell you about the film industry which
I've come to love you know the film
industry is the 21st century of
manufacturing film is is the type of
technology that New York excels at we
have the infrastructure we have the
train people and the next cycle will not
be driven by the industries are here and
I call that the fire economy financial
insurance and real estate because they
are portable industries they don't have
to be in New York they choose to be in
New York but eventually they're going to
go at the lowest place of up lowest cost
of operation because they have the
technology and the phones to do it but
by the nature of the film business you
require a very big infrastructure a huge
amount of plant and it's not easily
relocatable and it's so different you
can't just pick it up and move it and
it's so different than the other
industries we've had before there were a
clothing industry all kinds of things
but the film industry is the industry of
the 21st century and that's let me think
about that over so I'm the research
leader wife's not on some reason is he
the tech guy yeah that investor has come
I think I'll take this okay you have to
undress to it sorry way to do that or
she am your graduates start i'll just
play haha perfect okay great anyway oh
look I'm the research thing here and I
don't want to start with money despite
the fact that Dougal google has done
fairly well uh what I want to start with
is you guys we're here in your talent
this is the second largest convocation
of CMU alumni I gather and you're here
in New York so New York is an incredible
draw for talent that's why Google is in
New York more than anything else is that
it's a draw for talent and it always has
been and I think that's essential it's
particularly essential in the IT fields
I t is a field where all the opportunity
is fueled by extremely creative people
that see the connections between IT and
absolutely everything else everything
else is represented in New York if we
have the talent we combine them and do
this expanding sphere of IT into many
many directions and I think that's a big
part of the future thick New York will
play a big part in it because of its
talent what do you think about this view
though david had about about because
you're enabling the ability you need
talent and you need to go to the Centers
of talent but you're enabling a society
that can work anywhere to get
information instantaneously can work
anywhere and makes locus less important
well so in fact I give a talk and talk
frequently about something which i call
totally transparent processing right
we're translating amongst 41 different
language any words you can start and n
word up we're providing information on
every different kind of device in a
transparent way and operating across
different modalities voice image video
and a kind of convergent way as well and
trying to work across every corpus of
information so that's true we are trying
to break down all barriers and create a
really transparent world of information
sharing and communication but that being
said there's still a reason that people
want to be together
with other vibrant and exciting people
and we see that in our recruiting at
Google which we've done which we have
done and are doing a lot of we see that
across the New York area I don't think
you can break that down just because you
make communication really great Jay
you're an expert in electricity industry
is there enough energy to support new
york's growth and the concentrate it's
not just New York New York and you know
microcosmic way is the same as many of
the big city urban centers in Asia that
are growing now that don't have enough
energy to support their growth there's
New York have enough energy to support
its growth barely the answer is that New
York is not as bad off as we're just was
a week ago in Mumbai they're trying to
go from 20 gigawatts never mind the
units are 260 by 2030 but New York is
close to the edge the requirements of
New York say that there has to be added
between now in mid-decade the equivalent
of the Indian Point nuclear facility
that's about two and a half gigawatts of
power and it's just not happening and so
somebody's going to make some money
figuring out how to do that on how to do
it cleanly New York already has pretty
clean power it's got about third of its
power coming from nuclear about twenty
percent from hydro or and about a third
from natural gas it's very little cold
compared to the rest of the country
they're putting in a fair amount of wind
but it's going to be a tight squeeze to
get the power that New York me what do
you think the new the new power plants
will be for New York to use the biggest
new power plants are going in right up
by the Canadian border in there wind
wind but they only have but it's not
based look it's not base load they only
work about a third of the time the base
load stuffs probably going to be natural
gas and that's going to work just fine
until we won't run out of the Marcellus
Shale and then we're going to be seeing
big fleets of LNG tankers coming from
our good friends in Russia there
they have another important source of
growth in New York is of course the
financial services industry this
administration has been long on
regulation of the industry we're seeing
new regulation every day where do you
think this ends up how does the
financial services energy fair in how we
sort all this well fortunately this is
not the only country in the world doing
we regulation of the financial industry
and frankly they haven't really done
anything yet here they've done much more
in London which is the other real
competing financial center so there is a
little bit more Exodus or people talking
and also exodus from London also the tax
rates gone up in in England so you know
tax rates matter in that respect in that
respect but you know look I think the
point is that was made before this is a
place where people want to be whether
it's here and again it could be London
is another place people want to be
there's really no great center yet in
Asia financial center yet in Asia I'm
spect it will be at some point and there
should be at some point but there's no
there's no way that you're going to have
a financial center that's not new york
in this part of the hemisphere you'll
probably still have london even though
there's some migration out of the out of
the city right now for different
regulatory reasons but this is a
worldwide re regular this is just not a
United States phenomenon what is this
done to curb or or stymie the young
talent that wants to go into financial
aid of course you get bubbles and
financial services like you get in
consulting or you get into into high
tech and it generates a lot of interest
from youth coming through with
bachelor's and master's degrees what's
this done to youth wanting to go into
the industry i don't think i don't know
if it's if it's done anything yet would
you know it should do something because
they'll probably be less opportunities
at the big brokerage firms you know i
think one thing that's really hard right
now is the talking about it earlier with
the is it's harder to
to start a business for a lot of
different reasons one of that is a
fundraising it's very difficult right
now not just the regulation but you know
he's in the in answer to your first
question it is a little bit more
difficult to start a small for him
because of regulatory hurdles that are
just building make it much tougher to
start a firm you just need more people
more back-office people but you know it
gives a little bit of competitive
advantage to establish firms which is
also always a case with regulatory
hurdles there's nothing ever changes
that's the fact of regulatory hurdles as
far as young people going into the
industry it is still incredibly and
always will be very entrepreneurial you
can do very small firms or try to start
very small on your on your own you still
can it is a little bit more it is a
little bit tougher because of those
regulatory hurdles but you know it
definitely the app the environment is
definitely going to make it a little bit
tougher well then you're the new I'm the
next on the film uh-huh 21st century
industry well let me tell you why is
this it why how can this industry become
so so much bigger than it is now well
well and fill in some of these voiles I
see I was going to talk about a big jump
of two and a half billion dollars but
I'm ashamed to even bring it up when we
started out the new york film industry
was five billion dollars in three years
we've increased that to seven and a half
billion dollars we have perhaps a
hundred thousand people in the
entertainment industry and a seven and a
half billion that I'm talking about is
only about film and it only came about
one way because my son and I and a few
friends went up and lobbied for tax
credits through attracting new business
I mean that the state is giving away
money for people locate new office
buildings but we're getting tax credits
thirty-five percent of what we call
below the line that's the working people
not the salary so it isn't this like
food I mean how can I can consume more
and more intertech or are you talking
about video games that kids are into and
you're including all I'm just talking
about the film aspect it's a it's such a
big business and now we have two or
three hundred cable stations that need
product and the only thing that I think
gotta stymie as from doing it is not to
be able to depend on the continuation of
the tax credits because I took us some
people in New York and they say well
you've already got them here either no
you don't need to attract him anymore
I'm at a business where I have a factory
with five or seven stages but every six
months we have a new operator of the
factory he sets up a new machine shop he
builds he built sceneries he writes
scripts he comes in and at six months
he's gone so we have to continue that
and people are afraid to come here
because there's no continuity of the
guarantee of the tax credits which by
the way yield much more there is their
revenue positive both to the city and to
state but I don't think that's going to
happen because of politics every
politician thinks he has the answers and
they all know what to do but they don't
really understand our business we can't
be in business unless you're assured of
a prime aspect unless we have the
continuity of an assured disc of tax
credits we're never going to succeed
we're going to start to go downhill
unless we can convince the political
structure that it's a different kind of
business but the growth la is the center
there's no reason why we can't take it
from LA because everybody in the
industry wants to be in New York they
don't want to be in South Carolina or
Vancouver Mel Brooks said to me when we
had the opening of my studios and he was
doing the producer said you know why I
came to New York and why I don't like
Toronto because the bagels in Toronto
are too mushy that says a lot about New
York New York is where it's at we all
want to be here we just need a little
help to make sure that they stay we have
to get people to think about what's
important for the future Alfred you you
a lot of Madison Avenue do you take
strolls down mass and ever I think so
well I think we are and that's another
reason of course Google's in New York
near madison ave yeah so what no Madison
Avenue is the center of advertising
google has obviously changed the game in
advertising so the you know
does mess and Avenue change with you I
mean my experiences they've not been
changing quickly well I've been watching
madman in preparation for I love bed
mezzo know what what I think is going on
is there's a tremendous opportunity for
incredible creativity across advertising
broadly you just look at all the new
outlets for advertising all the new
forms of creative advertising that can
happen on those outlets they're
interesting questions on how to make
advertisements more valuable to the
people that see them and there are
indeed privacy issues around those
things but if advertising is really to a
large degree and information
dissemination mechanism which it is how
do you make it ever more effective in
that regard for mutual benefit of the
consumer and the advertiser they're all
the auction opportunities to deal with
the vast amount of space and property
that's available on which to do
advertising it's a tremendously rich
domain and it's it's a really
fascinating one there's every reason to
think they'll be need for immense
creativity to utilize all the
opportunity that's there how much to all
of you how much of New York's diverse
amount of a number of industries working
together in other words the way the same
way Carnegie Mellon thinks about its
multidisciplinary culture serving the
growth of the University in New York I
would imagine is the same way but you or
do you see stovepipes in New York where
financial services financial services
you know advertising is advertising tech
is typically do you think there is a
real benefit or competitive benefit to
New York because you we have such large
industries they can mix together and
become new morph into new new types of
opportunities or do you think it's just
simply destined as you know compete in
Australia's industry I'll go back to
what I said earlier I do think I t is
common to many industry
common to film it's common to finance
it's common to healthcare common to
education it's common to the media
advertising so I think because we have a
very talented IT sector here partially
because of the great universities
partially Bell Labs had a huge amount of
talent in this area and other research
labs and a lot of legacy there I think
that does tie us together and there's a
lot of fluidity and IT professionals
moving across domains we've seen that
I'd probably say the same in energy in
New York the folks that I see in the
finance sector are almost entirely
engineers or physicists that have moved
over into finance either from nuclear
and in the area that you know a lot
about in renewable energy there's no
question that that fluidity is going to
be absolutely critical we're seeing
we're seeing that struggle happen in
Silicon Valley now where we're a lot of
the investing that's happened in Prior
industries that are right for venture
capital light life sciences or IT they
there it was it was easy to found
companies to discover companies in
Silicon Valley grow them there and those
became the home of those those large
companies different tech companies and
life sciences maybe in Southern
California as well and now an energy
it's pulled us out of Silicon Valley
interesting the locus of talent is not
Silicon Valley in there we still see
companies born every day in Silicon
Valley people think they can do you know
something in energy with the smarts and
skills they have but we're being pulled
to the east coast we're being pulled
over being pulled to Germany we're being
pulled to China it's not a local
business at all I'd like to I'd like to
go to the floor to such as well to say
well we're talking please let's get a
micro want to say one more thing about
New York New York is the center of
everything it has the vitality it has
it's always been the growing place for
America all the immigrants that came in
from every culture and its continuing
everybody comes to New York and that
diversity it just makes things work you
could find somebody to do everything and
yeah
people here who have the guts and the
courage to step forward like being I was
only a builder what did I know about all
this stuff and you can do it here and if
you can make it here you can make it hey
well you had a computer coined as I I'd
like California was diverse too because
I went out there I found all these
liberals and and I thought boy this is
really diverse you're talking about my
people do we have a question from the
floor let's hope turn up the lights a
little bit and let's open this up a
little bit because we'd really we were
talking beforehand it would really like
to go with your questions as opposed to
my questions in the back gentleman has
his hand up you want to yeah good state
your name school okay great what can we
do to prevent the increased volatility
we there's threats of inflation the next
few years and New York is we see we saw
the New York of the 60 to the 70s we
don't want to go back to that period
where there was ten percent unemployment
for elongated periods of time how can we
use innovation in the next few years to
prevent this to get people into green
jobs quickly and to ensure the New York
doesn't have this blip short-term blip
where unemployment and the situation
becomes increasingly volatile we want to
take that you asked you asked four
different questions so I'll answer the
first question you asked because it was
I think it was a finance question and
somebody else can answer other ones
volatility to markets recent volatility
is a functional leverage if you regulate
or change the leverage in the system
you'll lower the volatility in the
system you know that's the main main way
to do it you know hopefully if they're
going to regulate one thing that's what
they should regulate in that respect
just one thing sometimes a little
volatility you know
on in a system is not a bad thing
because it creates innovation so
sometimes you have to create things
thumbs things that don't work overtime
have to be destroyed and other things
have to be created again so you don't
want to totally kill innovation you
don't want to totally kill creativity
and you don't want to totally kill
volatility for that reason but i'll let
up great answer do i want it when it's a
baseline question here is make sure we
capture these four questions and into
the really the baseline question which
is how do we produce jobs okay i'll tell
you what's the area biggest problem that
we have speaking as a small entrepreneur
and being friendly with other people you
can't get any money from the banks to
finance your business it's become
impossible lines of credit or not being
extended I you know I built a business
and real estate on mortgaging that's all
gone what are we going to do to do that
somehow the banks have to open the
spigot we've given the money and are not
using the money for what it was intended
a little guy can't get a letter of
credit he can't get money for payroll
you'll and this this country is built on
the basis of small business it isn't the
big corporations to make the job it's
guys like me and the other guy down the
street who has 30 employees and list the
banks are going to give us the money
we're not going to go anywhere well the
woody the mayor say about this in the
recent election sure I don't know I he's
happy he made it did he I mean a big
plan this is a big issue in California
twelve percent unemployment you know
what jobs are keep this mayor truthfully
did a fantastic job that this cut this
city's not bankrupt right now right so
you have to give what L love him hate
him who knows I'm on a New Yorker in New
Jersey unfortunately fortunately course
I'm not there anymore but it really was
a fairly fantastic jobs because and
other times when Wall Street fell down
this city really was on the brink of
bankruptcy and and you really had a
mayor that kind of had the foresight to
keep that from happening this time so
it's not never going to be perfect
but so I was just going to comment on
innovation so we have you know huge
things happening in the economy and
biotech and energy and information
technology and medicine and education
they're huge things so it's really going
to be I think our ability as a society
to leverage the opportunities innovation
and the new ways of doing innovation the
open collaborative platforms that we
have to work with each other to try to
try to leverage each other's talents I
think we have to have a lot of
confidence that innovation will in
effect come to the rescue of a lot of
this as long as we have the energy to
pursue it I agree with that I'd you know
having grown up in Pittsburgh i watch
Pittsburgh go through it the painful way
to lose the steel industry and to reform
itself and and it was kind of a
testimony to to the life of Pittsburgh
when when President Obama picked it as a
as a locus for the g20 but there's a
less painful way to do it and that is
through innovation and and keep that
innovation at home other question let's
yeah right here in front
hi Robert Albertson I was in Pittsburgh
for a long time very fortunate to have
gone to Carnegie I know all about
innovation I can't I can't say more good
things about it but this whole panels on
I gather you know where New York goes an
innovation what about the infrastructure
issues that hold it back so much the
power that we need is in Canada we can't
get it because we're gonna have a grid
we've got a water supply system going
through rickety tunnels of all the
cities i can think of in in in the
country New York is probably the most
vulnerable for the most mundane problems
and and those would be the ones that
would start the jobs and keep the city
going as much as innovation is a
fascinating subject the bedrock I I
worry is slipping away what would any of
you say to that so when you make comment
on a couple of infrastructure issues and
in one general thing the general thing
is that when I look at the difference
between here and some other place
soldiers by a week ago the difference is
confidence the folks here have the
confidence that you actually aren't seen
among some of the folks with the same
talent in Mumbai people in New York have
foot spa right you know how to get some
stuff done there is a wonderful new
water tunnel that's happening despite
all of the problems that were occurring
personally I think that what we're going
to see is a fair number of new natural
gas electricity units put in the city
and long island long island in the city
don't have many transmission lines
coming in so they got to have 90 or 95
percent depending on whether in the city
or long island of the power generated
locally it's been getting done and I'm
not that worried about the
infrastructure in New York I'm more
worried about the infrastructure in
places like Des Moines New York has the
confidence and you guys are getting
things done you really are Jay how do
how do we other than I guess natural gas
plants how do we get energy to
can be created renewable energy that we
created in other places you know it's I
think the Sun wind yup nuclear you know
they just not moving fast enough the
biggest new thing that hasn't been
tapped so far is offshore wind onshore
wind blows at night you know you as much
electricity at night except for that
spotlight there right offshore wind
blows during the day and I think what
we're going to see off the east coast is
going to be a fair amount of offshore
wind going in it's going to have a
higher duty cycle than the onshore wind
we're going to see some DC transmission
lines connecting it I think we're going
to see some new nuclear plants in this
country in the South probably a half a
dozen of them and if they work by work I
mean if they come in at good cost and if
the performance is good we may see a few
more nuclear is going to have to run
hard to stay in place we're going to
need of the order of 30 new nuclear
plants by 2030 to even keep the current
market share but I think there's some
innovations that you and I both know
about that we can't predict which one is
going to come on big but i think that
there's tens of billions of dollars in
some of those industries but it's not
the innovation it's not the innovation
here it's the fact that it's a NIMBY not
in my backyard you have when they won't
let go off of a you know in New England
or will they let wind go off of the
coast here they won't let nuclear in
Long Island they really close that plant
years ago yeah Dickey wind turbines and
Cape Cod I i think that the chances are
pretty good that you're going to see
european size wind farms off the east
coast of the US by off the east coast i
mean on the outer continental shelf on
the one that got stopped south of Jones
Beach got stopped for a few reasons not
least two which because it was very
expensive to put the pilings but also
because it was in a dumb place there was
only one substation you could connect it
because the innovations their eggs days
right I can't take a cell phone call
again put it
or in atherton I the other David once
agree with this David you know what the
problem is we've got a lot of projects
that need being done the infrastructure
in this country has been neglected for
20 30 years we have bridges falling down
we need water we need schools and here
we are throwing away all that money in
Iraq and Afghanistan for what we spend
one year we could have had all brand new
power plants in this country it's a
goddamn shame I think we've got to
refocus our energy and put our money in
America that's where it belongs okay
right there a hand up okay he's got the
microphone yes this question Gordon Ward
the hind school this question is for mr.
Steiner yes like to get your thoughts
about the growth of the film industry in
New York when you think about the cost
of doing business of filming in New York
given the the cost of dealing with the
the labor unions and then also from a
technology standpoint with the the
growth of special effects of being able
to use technology to give a New York
like feel without actually being in New
York well well let me tell you two
things about that first of all the film
industry likes to be under one roof
that's been the success of LA they want
to have everything we don't have a
special effects industry we really need
one in New York if we're going to
compete and we need more shops I hope
they don't come so soon till I make a
few bucks on my place but you need
places like we have three hundred
thousand foot of the latest up-to-date
technology so they can come in and
operate at low economical prices what's
happening now is because all the
decisions they all they run everything
and are exporting for the lowest lowest
possible cost and unless we can prevent
them somehow from shipping all the
business overseas we're just creating
competition instead of spending the
money here we're training a cadre of
people in New Zealand in Czechoslovakia
and they're all going to be our
competition let's put our energy here
somehow let's transfer this
center of power to New York that's where
it belongs I hope I answered everybody
hang out there has a comment on the
David's nimby issue I think could be
really interesting if anybody studying
this refer how will we change the static
energy in this country to give up what
we think is a right good right ok good i
have a mic i'm supposed to give players
a mic yes go ahead the other mic you
have control that's i'm a CMU mom I have
a son in the civil engineering
department who is very interested in
film and actually works for CMU
interesting that's what was I have one
question for professor apt in another
for the whole panel as regards energy
the NIMBY issue is enormous in New York
and that's why there are no more power
plants I grew up a few miles from Indian
Point and I don't think you'll ever see
another one built anywhere in the major
metropolitan area you didn't mention
solar energy and is that because we're
so overcast and the other question about
energy not as bad as Pittsburgh but
close there are things you can put in
water that take advantage of the
currents that I wonder if those wouldn't
work better in this whole area than
windmills because windmills are so
expensive and so politically undesirable
in people sight lines off the Hamptons
off of Massachusetts and so on so that's
one question the other is about the term
labor arbitrage at the same time my
heart my MIT son was filling out his
applications for the engineering
department there was there were stories
in The Wall Street Journal about
mid-career engineers training their h-1b
replacements and just as a panel up
there and as a university and as a body
of people looking at our future it's
just you know where is globalization
going to take us if it's taken the jobs
away from mid-career people thank you
okay let's try to do this
quickly jus dirt was going on first on
the tidal and wave energy there's a
company called verdant power that put
five turbines in the East River here
pull them out because of the problem of
biological fouling cook gets in them and
that's been the experience all over
there's a fair amount of energy in the
tides and the currents but it's tiny
compared to either wind or especially to
solar the reason why you don't see so
much solar isn't entirely due to the
cloudiness it's due to the cost solar
power is about five times as costly as
wind power which is in in turn about
thirty percent more costly than say
natural gas power but solar going to
come and silver cost is coming down fast
you bet you look at first solar or sun
powers projected costs they're going to
come down real fast for PV or even in
the solar thermal business which
probably has more of a floor but but
those PV costs are coming down very very
fast it probably this new york has
poured dni is it just doesn't get the
yield out of solar energy that a
California or New Mexico can get which
gets us back to transmission lines
that's getting the power because you can
ship electricity a long way with a ten
percent degradation so we need to
generate the power in the West get it to
the east so there's the electric on
hydro on hydro there I do I don't agree
with Jay totally I think small hydro has
a lot of potential you large hydro big
big dams we know about but small hydro
because there is innovation happening
with small hydro in streams and small
rivers and everything to deal with some
of that no I was just dressing the ocean
tower I agreed that there is small hydro
that can get it done and indeed New York
gets thirty percent of this sorry twenty
percent of its power the second question
was a bit you know it was kind of it was
really a globalization where a question
and how globalization what color
expressionist no no yeah I and you know
the thing with the globalization issue
you know it's unfortunate it is
absolutely
some industries are going to be losers
but the truth about globalization is it
makes the pie totally bigger for
everybody in the world and if you try to
stop globalization you make the pie
smaller now while you're making that pie
bigger and it work has work to make the
pie bigger here in general there are
people who will suffer you can't stop it
it's one of those you know this
volatility question from before it's
just can't stop and so it is an
unfortunate thing and policy in some
ways government policy is supposed to
help some of those people when that pie
gets smaller but long term you know the
will be people that will do certain jobs
that we do here we will do other jobs
here and the question is you just have
to let that take course and the
government probably has to kind of
smooth that over the different
governments of the world I think so i
don't know if that answers your question
but there's there's no limit to
innovation so if more innovation is done
in gently right that's fine and will do
more innovation here um talent is what's
going to drive though our capability so
when you look at all of these so-called
labor arbitrage issues the solution to
it is talent in the in education and of
course that's why we're here tonight
gentlemen I want to thank you for
participating in the panel and I want to
thank you
you